regardez ce que j'ai trouvé dans mon
jardin si les wallons ne prenne pas
froid et en particulier ceux qui passent
une partie de leur vie sur l'eau les
canards les mouettes et goélands c'est
parce que leur plumage est aussi et donc
une combinaison de plongée les plumes se
chevauchent comme les tuiles d'une
toiture
chaque plume se présente sous la forme
d'un axe central le rachis ce d'où
partent des arbres et de chaque barbe
des barbus munis de petits crochets qui
leur permettent de se maintenir les unes
aux autres pour former une couverture
bien étanche souvent on voit les oiseaux
aux fouilles et leur plumage avec leur
bec il se recoiffe il réaligne les
barbes et des bar bulles et les
enduisent d'une matière si rezé et
hydrophobe produite par une petite
glande située au niveau du tri pur c'est
très léger comme une plume ou une
capsule de déconfit n'est allé à demain
n'oubliez pas nous sommes confinés
mais en restant lire si vous avez aimé
cette capsule 2d confiné n'hésitez pas à
laisser un pouce bleus gens réalisent
une nouvelle chaque jour alors pour ne
pas les rater abonnez-vous et activer la
cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain